hey there I'm Jason guts and you're
listening to think again a big fink
podcast since the early days of the
public internet big think has curated
more than ten thousand surprising brain
bending significant ideas and shared
them through video text and social media
on the think again podcast we remix this
formula surprising me and my guests with
conversation topics that we didn't
necessarily come here prepared to
discuss today I'm very excited to be
here with Slava jiseok he's a cagillion
philosopher Lakhani and psychoanalyst
and political activist he's the interact
you drop communist political act and its
communist put a guide not intentionally
it wasn't in the back of your book maybe
your published record really steady it's
not up to you to decide okay
fair enough fair enough he's the
international director of the Berbick
Institute for the Humanities global
distinguished professor of German at New
York University and his newest book is
refugees terror and other troubles with
the neighbors against the double
blackmail welcome to thing against
lovely I'm glad to be here again I'm so
glad to have you today while we're
recording this I mean this will come out
a week later but we are voting in
America people are very emotional
they're very proud they're posting to
Facebook I had my nine year old son with
me in the polls today but reading your
book you know my sense is that you would
view the election sort of in a sense
whichever side you vote on it's it's a
broken system the whole thing needs to
be kind of redesigned in my last X on
the election ioniq Lee of course
referred to a famous answer by Joseph
Stalin who when asked in 1928 I think by
some official newspaper and of course
weak deviation is worse the right-wing
core the left brave he said both are
worse not both are equally bad but both
are worse and I think it's something
like this here on the one can tamp is
worse I mean the ideas that he stand for
all the white supremacy people blah blah
blah the it just max low
then at least the official ideology of
Democratic Party and all those lgbtq+
groups and so on that dissent behind it
and so on so Trump is worse but at the
same time in the forest rant and
although a bad change for some kind of
political dynamics right
Clinton is worse in the sense that he is
simply for that status quo and that's my
problem with Hillary Clinton she
reunited in a masterful ideological
operation everyone who is here early
Clinton from Occupy Wall Street to Wall
Street from LGBT black liberation gay
rights to Saudi Arabian money whatever
you want and I won and this the price
for this was of course Bernie Sanders
who was at least the beginning of a true
alternative had to be race had to
disappear and that's what worries me
with insurable win Hillary's victory
nothing will happen
it's the status quo which means that
probably in a couple of years late Trump
will be again here what I was not as it
was misrepresented for Trump I mean
makes me three yeah and let me let me
interrupt and and comment and yeah yeah
you know the Internet has been putting a
lot about articles out saying that
Flavell here is proach from when in fact
what he said was exactly what your in
what you said is what you're saying no
I'm just saying is you yet I'm trying to
hold view so that if I'm link you will
be lynched yeah yeah we hang from the
cell yeah yeah that we shoot without in
any case voting for Trump we should just
coldly appreciate this situation maybe
and Gronk I can even be convinced here
but right right what is Hillary wins
nothing changes and even more
dangerously what worse miss all those
big banks Cold War warriors like Val
Felicia and John standing with her I
think she will be this horrible
combination of some concessions to
progressive sexual freedoms blah blah
ah but it's part of the same package
with aggressive foreign policy and so on
and so on while with Trump disgusting he
is first I think this fear that
practically he will introduce fascism or
God
he cannot do it United States are too
complex a country and you cannot apply
to him this situation of 1933 were also
many less they thought it's better
Hitler that at least the front will be
clear movement on no no Trump cannot do
this Trump is not simply neo-fascist his
radical often confused opportunist he
often sometimes even said things which
make sense for example at a certain
point he said but we should show a
little bit more opening for for
Palestinian site also to see it then in
a typical Tramp way when there was a
Jewish backlash he said no no Jerusalem
is the eternal capital of Israel all
that stuff he radically apart uni I mean
I think the concern that a lot of people
have myself included is that he's
unpredictable we don't know what he
don't know yes I respectfully and agree
with you I think he has a lot of this
posturing and so on but I think that
basically in his acts he restin and a
very realistic opportunist and I don't
think I wouldn't even expect any big
changes with him in power what I do fear
I'm aware of the stuff first I know that
the very fact that he mobilized white
supremacy island zone is dangerous point
yes if he nominates all the judges in
the Supreme Court it's a problem but for
40 years
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but what I
nonetheless think is that his victory
which will not happen would have been
such a shock that it would hopefully
trigger a certain process which I think
would more or less certainly brought out
a certain revitalized
not communist leave but let's say Bernie
Sanders a step further and point to it
have been a great problem for Republican
Party although people think that know
all these opportunism different factions
in the Republican Party that in his
victory they would be united I don't
believe this I think that ok I'll put it
like this now I will say something
radical and
those people I detect in those moderate
leftist liberals rallying to this game
Oh Hillary's nonetheless the lesser evil
desperately in this record that they
secretly know that Trump means change he
is a voice of those enraged
disappointment which could be maybe
redirect that they are really horrified
at Trent as such they really I I quote
in my new text which appear digitally
online within distance two days ago I
quote a wonderful passage from George
Orwell who claims that today's radical
progressive talk a lot about change
about the necessity of change to make it
true that there will be no change you
know okay I think that this could I use
it are you saying that all change is
good I mean like no but shooting a
nuclear bomb at the US I know it's a
radical case but it's not good no but
I'm not gonna saying that this fear of
again I repeat the Trump is discussion
but the dig fear of Trump that it will
mean new fascism I don't share this fear
I think he's really a very opportunist
not I think I think it means significant
empowerment of some very very ugly
elements in American society which I'm
not saying are gonna be but vanish when
he is not elected but but at the same
time I think that the big problem of
United States from the very beginning
right hey be the last time of a strong
Socialist Party was I think in the years
not even decades after world war right
right right
no maybe yeah 1930s
facility down I think that once someone
is su p social so I think that what
would be wonderful news for the United
States is to make a step over this
radical eccentric circles and just this
one issue movement and so on like
recognize LGBT gay rights and so on to
make it into a serious much a little
much a little bit more radical political
source what in European terms would have
been not to moderate but not too radical
but a serious even social democratic
right right and that's for me the
tragedy of Hillary her greatest act will
not be defeating tram that was easy
right but defeating the threat of this
alternative Bernie Sanders so the one oh
I see I see so your issue as I
understand it from the book is with this
sort of tepid alliance of global
capitalism like that issues like LGBT
rights and whatever gets subsumed into
this giant global octopus of global
capital yes and it works and it works in
the sense of that's the big problem I
have become feminist and so on when I
claim to this bombastic my the
predominant ideology of today's global
capitalism in the developed Western
countries is no longer patriarchy and so
on it's precisely this type of let's
call it watered down
Judith Butler you know Judith Butler
okay
but watered down right in the sense of
this common perception of let's not have
a strands fix identity we need the
freedom to redefine ourselves to
reinvent ourselves right and this is why
also lgbtq+ fix it perfectly right idea
no fix divisions we always reconstruct
ourselves redefine ourselves and so and
you argue that that sort of easily
salute easily commodify i am lee here
that not so much commodified but i think
even for not only that it is easily
appropriated but that it is
fundamentally the ideology of today
global capitalism I know now also
identity politics equals global
capitalism with no it's no annoyed
Watsons equals if you deprive identity
politics of its social age and edge the
whole artistry of American mainstream
politics ok to be for identity politics
to deprive it of it more radical social
edge so that for example racing that's
why I criticize the notion of tolerance
tolerance means instead of political
struggle which is intolerant right the
problem becomes I'm Who I am
you are whom I am we should learn to
tolerate each other and so on and so on
yes not what even right-wing authentic
politics is authentic politics I have a
global vision which is different for
yours
let's fight without killing each other
but let's fight radically to the end one
really interesting thing in your book is
the chapter on the stranger and this
brings me to that the idea of the
neighbor and the chapters called the
limits of neighborhood and you quote
another writer and essentially say that
creepiness is the modern definition or
the modern sort of core of the neighbor
and you say you basically say we
shouldn't try and within this refugee
crisis and other other global issues we
shouldn't try to sentimentally
sympathize or empathize with the pain of
others but we should know I recognize
her alienation from them and I okay
something else ok I also quoted in the
book ok for example you know often we
encounter in politics for me at least
after stupidities which appear as wisdom
and I quote one you may remember which
is enemy someone to whose story we were
not able or ready to listen to right
right ok it sounds deep and it's
understandable like you have your own
vision I don't care it i stigmatize you
as the enemy I don't want to hear your
side of the story
sorry but this wisdom has great
limitations would you also say for
example that Hitler was our enemy
because we were not ready to listen no
there are real
enemies okay where the more you listen
to his story the more you should hate
him but speaking as one of these
liberals that you're sort of writing
against in that sector yeah because I
think I think I that's me I think that's
me least I can tell you something with
all my friendship when we the people
take over
you go to gulag but call me I will
arrange you get Giga rates and whiskey
there you will not suffer too much
oh let excellent excellent so we'll be
serving oligarchy No oh yeah so but but
I am not saying we should not understand
our neighbor and so on I'm just saying
there is a limit and true tolerance is
not this I should absolutely understand
you through tolerance is I don't
understand you because as they put it
clinically I think in the book you can
say that I even understand myself right
yeah true tolerance for me is not I
should understand all your meek and so
on through tolerance it we are in one of
this big around Washington Square these
high condominiums and so on and my ideal
is to live there next apartment is an
african-american next apartment and
Indian and Arab hard line drew Latino
American and we have polite relations
maybe maybe not I become friendly with
some of them but we fully respect each
other with all the differences they
almost my ideal society I don't like
this absolute pressure
I must understand you to the end know
the true miss the true even the true
love is this the true love now I'm
moving but it's a good parallel thing to
personal level I never liked this idea
of total love we think like one and so
on that's horrible in - laughs you live
to your beloved a certain autonomy you
know you cannot penetrate cannot
sexuality but mentally totally and so on
so why this obsession with understanding
the other to the end that's not the
problem and I think the problem is not
just vinegar drawn is that even if we
don't at this level of ways of life
understand each other we should build a
common front so my idea
that I always use this wonderful example
you remember - real square egypt
demonstrations okay till that point it
was always popular to say but can we
understand the Gyptians are they mature
for democracy when that happened all of
a sudden all those pretty problems of
multiculturalism do we understand them
disappeared and we were not wrong we
knew now we are on the same side this is
our shared struggle i I liked those
moments I don't think as some liberal
hynix would have said that liberals no
not you the desire this is just an
illusion no it's not an illusion this is
authentic universality which is always
the universality of a struggle not that
UNESCO book universality where old world
all world cultures are described as the
contributions to world humanity I
believe in a struggling universality we
have problems
Indians have problems are obsess
problems can we form a united front okay
I so I totally get that on the I don't
know I get it on the political level
here in the cultural level I understand
that we can't even understand ourselves
let alone understand another person
fully I also like also communities one
community one way of life right right
and I also understand something that
you're saying which I think is really
interesting which is that when we
attempt to fully understand one another
what we essentially do is impress a set
of assumptions upon the other which then
when they don't meet those assumptions
we get pissed off and we get angry or
insulted or whatever typical with
african-americans or will with with
Native Americans for example how often I
found my friend celebrating black
african-americans as wonderful the music
blah blah blah yeah but then when you
meet as every social group has it a more
brutal site whatever they get in total
panic you know all of a sudden
understand you know what's the problem
if I may use my old metaphor in the same
way that in today's consumerism we like
to get a product without it
laughs element right I coffee without
caffeine beer without alcohol sausage
without fat we like to get a neighbor
ethnic other without its dark side a
kind of a purified decaffeinated
neighbor I call them you know so bad for
me true respect for the neighbor is that
precisely you accept the neighbor not as
someone who should not be criticized but
you accept him precisely as someone with
all his weaknesses horrors respectively
get engaged in a dialogue with me not
this pattern izing respect which is
false also in some ways I guess what I
want to say though is that I think that
there is a type of empathy and that
there is a value of empathy which is not
sentimental or patronizing and which is
actually a willing at any rate to find
some kind of common ground with other
human beings and I I don't know if these
terms are even meaningful anymore but in
a way it seems like what you're
describing is a very kind of what I
would think of or would have thought of
at one time in history as a very
masculine perspective a kind of like
robust like let us make fun of each
other and go to battle together now the
ultimate surprise I which is not to say
only human but no it's a good feminist I
will tell you which notion of
masculinity femininity you have here
these roles are historical and trained
for example now comes the big I think
that the very couple Trump Hillary Trump
Clinton tells us a lot till now we have
a certain notion of masculinity which
was predominant right it was I follow
here my good friend Alain Badiou who
develops this in his new book which was
defined by a certain right of maturity
okay like in traditional societies but
this meant in 30 40 years ago you become
really a man
after some initiation either in Europe
which was typical after you serve the
army that was the initiation or as to
refine to permanent job or after you get
married or even after you seen if your
study
now this symbolic moment of initiation
are disappearing no longer have wait
right men are more and more this is a
tendency but a profound one defined by
their let's call it a prolonged
adolescence right you are never mature
even when you are adult you remain an
adolescent right and then women very
interestingly are to a large extent
treated as prematurely mature already
girls are treated as women responsible
for them so what is happening in our
social space is that because of this
lack of moment of initiation which
provides you with a certain identity man
then look for a that in half illegal
gangs and so on all that stuff violence
and so on while women are emerging as
something much more interesting there is
a new figure of power today which
mobilized a certain traditional features
of femininity not just brutality but
comprehending understanding prior week
six let's call it post or Italian
sanctioning of power even better but you
quote a wonderful example he says look
at a typical French courts for young
delinquents the typical scene is a young
immigrant working class boy non
socialized immature part of a gang right
treated for him by faces of power which
are for him
predominantly feminine drug his family
judges psychiatrists and so on so I
think that this new duality man is
immature irrationally aggressive
exploding not controlling himself on the
other hand woman s more compassionate
and so on right but at the same time in
an hour
I'm first let me make it clear I'm not
saying these are women I'm here
I'm totally Pro feminist I'm just saying
this is one position witness of power
which is today
for two women okay my point is this one
is not an ideal example of this decouple
Donald Trump Hillary Donald Trump is the
ultimate is he a perpetual adolescent
what is that he just explodes as listen
well Hillary is this ultimate
manipulative woman and even I heard some
rumors
who knows if they are true that even
this is how their true personal
relationship works it's okay with I mean
Hillary and Bill and Bill it's Bill who
is now more weakened the world weakened
and Hillary already in the Lewinsky
affair she was not that all crying what
are you doing but totally in control
strategic she was okay go to play with
Monica but I'll do the serious block
know it in other words I like to see
this couple Hillary and Trump yeah as a
new version of sexual difference of
gender roles by emerging in late
capitalism they are not only bad for the
men but also bad for the women from
allows women more power but only if you
obey this brutal commercialized
commodified rules of feminine
manipulation and so on this worries me
no no it's not only here look I even in
a certain way I even admire this did we
notice that in the last decades if you
want really tough job done Margaret
Thatcher Indira Gandhi where you need a
woman and I like that even in Germany
Angela Merkel was a nice number I
understand what you're saying
I understand now I am NOT saying that
this is an argument against who hit me
yes how are you no it's just that we
have women demand for power I totally
agree with them and then in a tricky way
it offers you okay you women one power
hero habit in this here's how you have
to give you four for me
yeah or whatever and this is a very
thick tendon here yes I I but I can
totally buy that I guess why do i no no
again going back to what we were saying
before I think you proposed a dichotomy
which may exist but that the soul binary
in that dichotomy doesn't have to be
between sentimental
insultingly superior kind of pity for
the other and on the other hand this
sort of distance and solidary I don't
think those are the only like I think
that there is there are visions of
coming to understanding understanding
the other understanding is a very
painful long process which goes well
beyond any kind of right you know in one
sense you know I will tell you how you
would probably not agree with it I think
it was the only moment I come to an
understanding with my Chinese friends I
was there at the philosophical
conference and okay we just talked
obviously we talked empty and then
somebody attacked me and the another guy
attacked me but they attacked me in a
totally different way they ended up
attacking Kitsch and I was able to
identify with that struggle all of a
sudden there were no problems I was
fighting for one against the other you
know to understand a culture is
ultimately to understand their problem
their antagonism that would you buy I
don't
otherwise you mystify the other into
this you know they leave some organic
meaningful life they know we are all in
the same shit like I don't believe in
some people they're like this or even
weak evolutionary activist but what
about what about the like psychological
experience of being a person and like
having a kid and for example let me give
you an example really quick and then
move on to the next thing after I hear
your response you know there's this guy
he works in the parking garage where we
park our car I hear ya guys is a guy
yeah yeah um he a few days ago like I'm
like how you doing you know we I didn't
know anything guys from the Dominican
Republic I see him when I party or I
said how are you doing and he's like not
so good and I'm like what's going on and
it turns out his daughter who's like 30
is in a coma and he and I had a moment
like she just fell into a coma and like
I had a moment where I stared across the
abyss know between your culture and
everything else that divides me in this
guy and I just like hug
man I don't know I don't know do you
know I don't I totally believe in such
moment yeah but you saw that it was a
moment of pain of mandalas yeah had to
be this I think but that is a common
human experience I have lost people I am
NOT his experience is not my experience
yeah yeah there's some resonance there
otherwise we couldn't have wait a minute
I don't give anywhere although some
multiculturalist will again complicate
the game telling queue but how do you
know that the loss of a child means the
same thing
I don't entire totally I love it but
there was a thing you know there that's
what I mean yeah I think that you were
right this was a universal a genuine
universal moment and I don't believe in
this
Eldo intellectual complication but how
do I know that morning means the same
thing to you as to him no I believe in
this magic moment of sharing intimacy I
totally believe okay
genuine reversal all right I wanted to
ask you about that after reading your
book and then this happened you don't
know um so let's get to the second part
of the show there's a sweet surprise
yeah the terror video or where these are
these are video I suppose you you
already had them there they sent them to
me I've not watched I swear to you no it
looks you're bad yeah I am bad but not
so bad
alright so the first one with Scott
Barry Kaufman who is the director of
something called the imagination
Institute
I'm an idiot I don't know anything I
don't know what that is either I'm also
an idiot on that score of the probe and
it's called there is a way to unlock
human potential but it's not
standardized testing
the idea of what we should be testing is
a very hotly debated because there's a
certain objectivity that we think we
have once way standardized things and we
give it the same test to everyone and
there is some truth to that that the
more you standardize a test the more you
kind of give everyone the opportunity to
perform on that test there so there is
some argument to be made towards
standardization but we don't have
standardized minds I mean no one has a
standardized mind there's no such thing
as as an average mind so every one of us
every unique individual is a dynamic
system of not just cognitive processes
but motivational processes dreams
desires I formulated a theory called it
the theory of personal intelligence
because I argued I wanted to shift our
focus of analysis from compare taking
one aspect we say well this is we've
decided as a society that's our measure
of intelligence and then we compare
everyone to each other on that one
metric so when it comes to testing I'm
not necessarily against testing and not
actually against using standardized
tests as a way of measuring learning
outcomes but as a way of measuring human
potential not down with that
it sounds nice but I'm a little bit
suspicious I thought you were because I
don't like this focus on individuals
uh-huh because this can ultimately also
mean there are no idiots because it
reverse has individual standards and so
on of course this is even in the banal
way true but there is nonetheless
something in between this Universal
tests and your unique individual
composure is my god we are not born as
individuals we are raised through
internalizing certain standards of our
way of life and so on and so on right
I'm 11 communities will remain enter
these communities precisely always
involves a certain balance between
intellectual emotional organized at
Oriel capacities and so on and so on so
yes we should demystified tests they
don't measure an objective property of
yours and so on but they can well
measure how do you stand with regard to
what your community expect from a
successful or bright or whatever human
being and here things get for me
complicated because as I was yeah if you
don't fit this model it's not as simple
as to say but maybe you have your own
standards yes you have your own
standards but you know like 101 of 99
people this your own standards mean you
are drop out right and every 100 even
less make out of this distance something
creative and you explode right and I
think it's too cheap to say yeah
creativity in everyone and so on and so
on
again creativity it's very problematic
term what do we mean by creativity
I mean creativity is again the term
which I would return to him to this guy
his own argumentation and say what does
he mean by creativity different cultures
appreciate creativity in the difference
for example in some cultures it's a
creative way
ish what ironically referred to as D how
to call them is the Lee Strasberg act oh
sure sure sure yeah that creativity
means you openly bring out right right
right right I'm horrified
there's a famous do you know this famous
allegedly there was a conversation
between Laurence Olivier and Dustin
Hoffman on the set of Marathon Man yeah
where I was totally this is my favorite
dentist movie I'm totally on the site of
of Lawrence yeah Olivia said yeah so so
for the audience Hoffman has been he
comes shows up on set he's been up all
night he's exhausted in order to try to
get into the character using the method
and and he's too exhausted to act and
and Olivier allegedly said to him my
dear man why don't you just try acting
yeah and yeah and you see for me
although it was less of this creativity
imagination it was much more intelligent
this typically British very strange
right Laurence Olivier you know even we
don't even agree how we measure
creativity and so on I'm here more on
the side of this risk although it may
appear almost ironic the way I shout
okay but I'm intimately much more
sympathetic with this British or
conservative Japanese approach where
they claim true creativity is not in
this explosion of remove it ideas true
creativity should appear as modest
invisible you apparently do nothing
nothing big but all of a sudden you
appear that everything is different
everything changed you know also it's
much more it even more complex than he
imagines and that's why I think he's not
totally right well so I I want to
introduce another kind of complexity so
you know what you're saying on the one
hand is that cultures have different
values and different definitions of
intelligence creativity etc and what you
described was really a cultural or a
personal preference for one style over
another you you personally are sort of
allergic to the the kind of emotion
based explosion based
form of creativity yeah but I will give
you another example sorry very funny now
I remember you know I'm Goldman the
producer was well known for his
so-called Goldwyn isms yes apparent
nonsense is but well thought out so once
ok actually you know what I'm sorry
could you briefly explain what record
when a Sam Goldwyn was the big Metro gas
producer who was well known for
apparently making stupid mistake okay
but which is very intelligent betrayed
so one of the stories of who is that he
read in a newspaper the complaint that
in the scenarios of the films he is
making right there are too many old
cliches okay and he wrote a memo to his
screenplay scenario Department we
urgently need more new original cliches
and was deeply right creativity is not
to break out of cliches are installed
new cliches I say assess for me through
creativity every idiot can be creative
in the sense of I'm out of cliches and
shown the truly difficult thing is to
propose a new cliche I think that that
second kind that you're talking about is
also more sustainable like if you're if
you're the sort of expressionist
exploding creative that I can only last
so long I you are in a manner like a
Jackson Pollock right I he wrote
abstract expressionist Mark Rothko not
Jackson Pollock interesting okay
so but what I was gonna say also though
is that the problem going back to
standardized testing one of the problems
is that I don't know that societies know
what they value what I'm trying to say
is that I'm not sure that standardized
tests always actually or accurately
represent anything like the values of
absolutely obvious yeah but why even
expect this from standard test and so on
yeah what I'm on the other hand not
against is that let's be very brutal you
have a certain opening for a job right
and you don't care about creativity blah
blah you want people who are well doing
something right and I think you should
have the right to test them and you
don't pretend like you test me right I
can then claim oh but you missed all my
other credit creativity's and you can
say screw
I'm not buying you a paraffin I need you
for this and I need you to have this
problem right right I don't find there
anything ready fight
alienated and so on and so on but like
if you are hired for a professor of
mathematics yeah
certain abilities and I don't give a
shit if you get have an emotional
ability right right right right right
well it gets even slippery er though
like you know for professor of
mathematics that's one thing that's well
I won't call it concrete but it's a
little more concrete in some ways than
what is needed in say a middle manager
in a corporation dad and I agree very
many meats that they don't make it's
very confusing and they have no idea
what like when they hire people they
don't know what there is yeah no I
totally agree be are you I even for
example my good friend varoufakis
Yanni's the criteria he told me before
he became fracas well no no he asked me
why don't we write a book on political
economy an economy together I said but I
don't have any idea what economies do it
don't be neither do economists you know
great science of magic like astrology
super vision and so on so this is very
deep think what you said especially
people who pretend to understand other
psychological advisers and so on and so
on
even Planko analyst right shocks me
again and again how for example
psychoanalysts whom you would expect to
have a refined nose for subtle nuances I
met so many not stupid but brutally
insensitive psychoanalyst yeah who like
much more than an average person don't
get the point
like somebody can be making a tragic
appeal they dismiss this as does the
empty aggressivity or whatever it makes
you very pessimist as it is however the
specialists don't get it
because the people who ever escape
keeping in those fields does they can't
agree upon what constitutes a good
psychoanalyst ever yeah but the problem
is that you know this is the law of
bureaucracy and all institutions you
don't really want to solve a problem you
want to guarantee
your reproduction right and so so you're
mitigating risk mostly like yeah yeah
shall we so a Mexico that whoever I feel
not give me oh I don't want your wife to
kill you that would be terrible we will
do one more okay and this will be Daniel
Bergner who is an author and a
journalist saying neuroplasticity
explains why women may be less
monogamous than men there's some pretty
stark research out there now that just
talked about one study this was done by
German scientists look at 2500 committed
couples a no small number the results
are probably no fluke and he measured
their desire progressively over time the
desire starts at right about the same
point for the men and for the women so
again debunking this idea that somehow
male desire male libido is far stronger
innately than female libido but what
happens interestingly is that male
desire declines gradually over time
female desire dives much more
dramatically than male desire within
those committed relationships and I
think two things are worth saying first
again the very least this calls into
question this idea that somehow women
are comparatively better suited to
monogamy than men are but second has to
do with cultural lessons and their
effects on the brain so I think most of
us have heard this phrase or at least
are familiar with the concept of brain
plasticity that is the brain is shifting
neurologically in response to what we do
with it well what happens to the brain
if we're taught very different lessons
about sexuality from early on boys are
of course taught right from the
playground really that being a little
bit of a Romeo all to the good girls are
taught a very different and more
constrained lesson even in our seemingly
unconstrained society
can you help me but yeah yeah yeah yeah
maybe I didn't quite get the point at
the point is I know how with women it's
declined earlier no he's saying in
committed relationships that meet that
wait a minute he did he mean when he
spoke about how women's heroes right
declines much faster yeah did he mean
generally the erotic desire of women or
concretely the desire to your partner
the latter desired it was not clear from
my understand well okay my understanding
of what he was saying was that he's
proposing that women may be young less
inclined to monogamy than men why
because - yeah that it's strange because
it's like society conditions them not to
be sexual beings and therefore sexuality
drops off faster in relationships but
then why wouldn't it why wouldn't it
traffic another problem nonetheless
women in spite of games of feminism and
yes still more sexualized even and give
you one measure yeah it's still
considered normal and I'm happy to enjoy
this to be married to 30 years younger
woman okay some people a little bit
ironic but no problems right if I were
to be thirty years younger being married
to thirty years older than me woman
right then it's a fight of all King of
all changes brought by feminism it would
cost much graters animosity ironic
remarks at least and so on and so on so
I think that I'm not actually I'm not
sure I agree you really know okay baby
notice because honestly I think there
are a lot of people in the United States
who would view the like older man
younger woman relationship and make
catty snotty ironic marks and say oh
look at here you're fishing for the
young yoga I know and and and the other
way around I guess it wouldn't generally
cool but I think it would engender in
America more bafflement I think people
would be like confused they'd be like
why is that irony yeah no nice to ask
what does heat he in her not in an
ironic way but genuinely like why is
that woman so attractive and so on but
okay then I will put it in this way
wouldn't it be more logical in an
abstract way from this decline of desire
right right but in if in the marriage we
have this gap right like when you are
married 15 years
your wife's desire declines so you
should be the one looking for it
elsewhere then and right right I didn't
get it
well that makes sense well I think what
I agree with sorry is plasticity that
you know the way our brain is all
permanently restructuring itself it
matters a lot and so on and so on also
again we have to be so precise here I
think that it's with men
still this is traditional identity I
know but it is anything till recently it
was much more considered normal for a
woman to be more exclusively mother stay
at home right and men is the one who
goes outside right travels
does the job and so on now the truly
interesting they would be this one if
you are passing I cope we are from this
to this post patriarchal family where
woman is also expected to make a career
and so on cash how does this shift
affect the permanence of sexual
excitement of desire like what did their
relative at least emancipation and this
is a great game for women yeah that it's
considered normal
you're not a pathological frigid woman
right - if you want to make a career
gain how does this affect women's desire
diminish it or does it really string I
mean that's a great question and and I
think one thing I wanted to say or that
I thought about watching this video is
how mysterious sexuality remains and
maybe that's a good thing we don't going
back to what we were saying before about
experts like nobody is the expert on it
it's this very murky scary realm people
don't talk about it in much I mean they
do among friends or whatever but as a
society the data exists but but not in
any consistent or robust way so people
can come along and claim this or that
may be the case about women's sexuality
could be too late the problem is that
probably the guy has more behind yeah
yeah from this clip it simply appears to
me but I don't blame him because I
didn't get enough background data right
it wasn't clear I see so many other
options to interpret this like when he
said we follow 250 couples or whatever a
relative example well I would like it
what I would be much more interested is
if we're to compare one group of couples
which remain married all the time and
others which got divorced and so on
women are and men other partners and how
does this affect your desire and so on
there are so many other venues here that
I simply yeah fair enough but going back
to one thing I think and then we can
wind it up have you seen the film Harold
and Maude do you know the film Harold it
totally forgot about baby need 30 years
yeah yeah it's Hal Ashby film and like
Maude is an older lady and Harold is
discontent in his life and he falls in
love with her and I that's the only film
I mean I thought of it because of what
you said it's the only film I know of
and it's the only piece of litter like
we all know Lolita right which disgust
sighs yeah on the other hand because
we're like we can't believe your
intensity of this somewhat likable
narrator's affection for this young girl
with Harold and Maude it's trying to
show you know she's she Maude must be 80
and Harold is maybe 20 so radical yeah
and he falls in love with her sexual
love or no it's love love she opens his
world he's in a very constrained family
environment his mom is rich he's she's
constantly trying to give him presents
like a Jaguar which he converts into a
hearse you would enjoy this film I think
but but no
something else that you must be
interesting movie because one of my
absolutely favorite Hollywood movies is
did you see also college beat being
there yeah yeah I'm a movie about
transference how a complete idiot if you
find yourself at the right place yes it
produces magic and so on
I like this regional then the guy says
total platitudes and they are over
interpreted as wise instruction into
politics and so on and so on that's the
reality of our lives I think it's one of
the most radical wonderful movies it's
incredible yet Peter Sellars is based on
a book by apogee stern European a guy
yeah yeah yeah and then there is another
role it's a king Shirley MacLaine yes
yes yes and yeah and he's just he's a
gardener with limited mental capacity
and then he and everyone thinks he's a
genius because he speaks in sort of Zen
koans which are not but notice that they
are common sense statement because he
occupies the position of a genius
they are interpreted as and and and you
feel that that defines much of our
intellectual life maybe not in section
III or ever so much depends on how you
are interpreted right I often noticed
this when people take me seriously as a
philosopher I say something vulgar they
look something from it
right from other people I can develop
what I think is well a nice line of
thought they dismiss it as meaningless
and so on so much depends on this
horizon of expectation how you approach
it how do you feel about this weird like
I keep seeing this the Elvis of
philosophy that seems incredibly
insulting leaks to me again and again I
protest to my publishers please don't do
this
yeah and it just sticks it's so it's so
dismissive of what is obviously a
serious body of work yeah but that's why
when people they'll be how does it feel
you are a star of philosophy I claim no
being called Joseph II popular a refined
way to attack me a way to say oh you are
a funny guy
but not too serious man today stop okay
yeah yeah you have to go out how to get
rich and that wraps up this week's very
spirited episode of think again I hope
that you enjoyed that half as much as I
did it was pretty amazing on this
election day to have that rapid-fire
intense conversation and now let me head
off you're going to be hearing this I
guess about a week after the election
but I'm going to go ahead off now and
sit with my family in a bar somewhere in
Queens and watch the election results
with my fingers crossed and my breath
held we have tons of interesting
episodes coming up for you I'm not going
to let the cat out of the bag if you
haven't read it or reviewed the show if
you liked the show and you haven't rated
and review or reviewed it on one of your
favorite platforms that you listen to it
on I would really really personally
appreciate if you could do that hope to
have you back next week
take care
you